I served in the United States Marine
Corps for four and a half years I found
Hillsdale at the end of my last
deployment applied and came here
basically three weeks later
Hillsdale stood out from the other
colleges that I was looking at and that
it emphasized teaching you how to learn
not what to think and so I felt like I
could take that and kind of become a
learner for the rest of my life rather
than just learning for four years once I
decided to come to Hillsdale the big
flashing question was what about
financial aid I was just so impressed
with how eager they were to help me get
here private donors had stepped in and
ended up providing basically a full ride
for me the full four years here at
Hillsdale and it's amazing to see that
because they understand how valuable
this is I think for most of the people
coming from the military they already
have this deep sense of love and respect
for our country but there's a lot of
room for understanding what that country
is and the things that really that
established it and have preserved it the
liberal arts and the education here will
not only give you that but so much more
this foundation not just for government
and how we live in society together but
in your own life an understanding of
what it means to be human and how to
live the best life you'll be able to
apply that and take that to whatever
career path or wherever it is you go or
whatever that you want to do that's
going to inform every aspect of your
life